what were your writing flaws when you
were accepted to the CSUN program what
did you want to work on or was it more
to just experience something else oh
they're very specific things the one
thing when I finished rising star when I
look back at the script the structure of
that film could have been so much
stronger but I didn't know how to get it
there and I knew it when I watched the
film you could see it that something was
missing and it wasn't wasn't in the way
that it was directed what not the way
that it was edited or music anything
that technically it was fine because I
had great people working with me
but the story really wasn't enough to
keep people's interest for 90 minutes so
part of me going into CSUN was a real
desire to study structure and to study
German you know dramatics the basics of
dramatics that was something that I
never really had when when I went to
Florida State that were writing classes
but it really was more short film based
and kind of a formula based I guess is
the best way to put it you know like
somebody has a goal am an obstacle and
they try to fix it all in five minutes
so I understood that but how do you
transpose that into a 90-minute film
where you have to keep somebody's
interest and there has to be a growth of
the character and things like that I
didn't really understand that so and
this is having taught a screenwriting
class before when I got to this point I
still realized okay I was able to teach
this to some undergrads to the point
where they could understand it in a
short film format but I didn't get it
from the feature-length format at that
point so when I got there part of the
reason why I applied there was professor
Edson Eric Edson he has a book on
structure so that's specifically like
that's his bailiwick that's what he
makes his money on so I really wanted to
work with him so that I could really get
like a crash course on that and it
really helped it really really helped
and the best part was that wasn't the
only paradigm that I was able to be
exposed to and the probe
a number of the professors that I had
went to USC for screenwriting and they
have a different way that they teach
screenwriting it's the eighth sequence
method I had never heard of that before
so after learning with Eric for a little
while then I started working with these
other professors who were talking about
the eight sequence method and that made
even more sense to me because professor
Edson is really his structure analysis
is really granular it's down to the
moments eight sequences a little looser
it's not as it's not as exacting where
things have to happen by a certain point
so the combination of learning both of
those Styles really helped me sort of
figure out okay the stories that I want
to tell can fit into both of these
paradigms just not completely one or the
other
so now I'm at a point where when I when
I have an idea for a story I can sort of
see where it fits isn't more according
to how Eric teaches it or is it more
according to ain't sequence so it really
is nice now where I can understand you
know there's a certain kind of story
fits a certain kind of structure and I
didn't get that before so that going
through school really helped me you know
sort of learn to identify that that's
interesting what type of story
fits one versus the other or were there
movies that plugged into both there's
others definitely movies that plugged
into both in fact the the eight sequence
method is you can graft 8 sequence on to
Professor Edison's structured paradigm
the difference is 8 sequence can allow
you to sort of go off and follow other
characters in certain moments but then
you come back to the main story after a
certain amount of time and that made
more sense to me because the stories I
want to tell are a little bit more
character based they're a little bit
looser they're not really the the
tightly structured narrative blockbuster
kind of stories that's not the kind of
thing that I want to do and those are
primarily the films that Professor heads
and analyzes when he talks about his
method
so to see eight sequins and to see that
you can sort of take little side tracks
every now and then and go on tangents
before coming back to the main story
that made more sense to me so but since
I know both of them you know I can I can
kind of see okay this independent film
goes on you know it goes on different
tangents and goes in different places
but it's still effective because it
follows a lot of the things that are
also common in professor Ed's in this
structure if that makes sense yeah I'm
just trying to think of like would would
maybe crash and Goodfellas something
that has sort of more of an ensemble
cast fit into that eight sequence yes
yes absolutely ensemble pieces are
certainly eight sequence good ones you
know road trips can sometimes fit well
and they fit well into both but I think
they work well than eight sequence
horror film I don't know if you ever saw
misery
that's a great example of an eight
sequence film because when the sheriff
goes looking for the writer for about 10
15 minutes you're following that
character you're not following the lead
of the movie and then at the end of that
sequence we come back to the main story
so that's an example of that interesting
and what what films would fit more into
Edison's professor Edison style
you think of you think of any popular
film you know that's come out Legally
Blonde
will be a great example of a very
traditionally structured film that falls
into his style collateral is another one
that does where you have a character
they have a they have a number of
actions that they have to complete over
the course of the film and by completing
those actions they open up more problems
for themselves and that's what sort of
drives the story is them overcoming
those problems as the story continued
it's kind of it's a little hard to talk
about in the abstract but it's professor
Edison says that every every major story
hero has 23 major goals that they need
to accomplish over the course of the
film and then there are certain moments
that sort of shift what it is that
they're trying to get
and then over the course of the film
they learn something in the quest of
trying to accomplish all of these goals
again it's very simplistic but that that
is a little bit more exacting and a
little bit more I guess know what the
right word is specific than eight
sequence which is which gives a little
bit more room for playing around I think
I know he uses Erin Brokovich and which
is a fantastic film and I went out after
interviewing him I went back and watched
it I'm like this really isn't a maid
like Susannah grant it's such an amazing
job Oshin really and and even though
Julia Roberts even though Julia Rock
even though the Erin Brockovich
character Julia Roberts interacts with
these different people that have been
affected by the situation it is really
mainly her about her journey whereas the
single mom is kind of trying to prove
herself right you know and and deal with
all these things that are being thrown
at her yeah so even though you could say
well there's a huge cast that's involved
but it really is her specific journey
right and and so her goals would be you
know to talk with to talk with one of
the victims of PG&E right and then based
on that she learns something which he
calls fresh news I don't know if he
mentioned that oh and then that
motivates her to the next goal so she
learned something with this first client
then her next goal is to go to City Hall
to look at topographical maps of the
city to find out where things are you
know and then she learned something
there and that gets her to another goal
so that's sort of the the step by step
process that Professor Edson teaches and
it's there you know when you watching
her in Brockovich it's all there and
through those goals she learns to have
the self confidence that she never had
when she was a kid right and she based
it on her looks and she still uses that
when she goes to the City Hall right
that's a great sea Krait right there in
within Nasri - uh-huh right that's true
and then she goes back to law office and
then they're all giving her these dirty
looks but she's still trying to prove
you know with Albert Finney's character
that like let you know let me keep doing
this
doing this and it's a great it's just a
great character study yes really is at
some beautiful film
you